did people say to you why why Cindy why  risk yes those lucrative endorsement  deals  yes but part of my agreeing to do  playboy the first time that I did it  manager so I was like 21 was that we  would do the pictures Herb Ritts and I  were doing a shoot for French Vogue  anyway in Hawaii and we just decided to  tack it on to that job so it wasn't like  a huge production and I said I don't  want a lot of money up front but I want  the control I want to be able to approve  every picture and if I don't like the  pictures or don't like the way the story  turned out I want to be able to kill it  is that because when you're posing nude  I mean you've got to trust the  photographer if something's hanging out  that you really don't want people to see  you've got to have that editorial  control if you give that to playboy  they're going to go for the most  salacious picture right I I guess at  times that that would be true so you  felt safe with I only read the articles